المترجم: Haya Al-Hady
المدقّق: Anwar Dafa-Alla
بالأمس
كنت أقرأ الجريدة فوجدت
خبرا لطيفا حمسني جدا
طالب مصري في احدي المحافظات في الاعدادية
اخترغ جهاز لمعالجة السرطان في نصف ساعة
فرحت جدا
هذا هائل فسوف ننقذ البشرية
رائع
ثم عرفت أن مصر تتذيل التقارير
الدولية في التعليم الأساسي
اندهشت
ثم وجدت أن الدول التي تتصدر هذه التقارير
طلابهم في الاعدادية لا يخترعوا شيئا
فاندهشت أكثر
هل يعقل أن بعد كل تلك المصروفات
و المجهود المبذول في العملية التعليمية
لم يتمكن طالب من أن
يخترع حفار بالليزر لتعمير المريخ
ثم وجدت أن الطلبة المصريين دائما
ما يربحون في المسابقات العلمية العالمية
لم أعد أعرف من أصدق
هل أصدق التقارير التي تقول أننا متأخرين في
التعليم الأساسي علي مستوي العالم؟
أم أصدق نتائج الطلبة المصريين الذين
يربحون في المسابقات العلمية العالمية؟
اذا فكرنا في تلك المسابقات
سنلاحظ مشكلة
سنقسم هذه المشكلة الي قسمين
القسم الأول هو المادة العلمية
و القسم الثاني هوالفكرة التربوية
بالنسبة للمادة العلمية
سنلاحظ أن الطلبة المتحمسين
لدخول تلك المسابقات
دائما ما يكون هدفهم هو الاختراع
و ليس أن يتعلموا
يفقدون دورهم كطلبة علم
كمثال
كان لدي طالبة
قالت لي
أريد أن أخترع خلية شمسية دائرية
كي تنتج أكبر كمية من
الطاقة الكهربائية من أشعة الشمس
فرحت جدا و شجعتها
فسألتها مم تصنع الخلية الشمسية ؟
لم تكن تعرف
لم تكن ملمة بالأمر
ثم سألتها عن عملية تحويل
الطاقة الشمسية الي طاقة كهربائية
تعجبت كثيرا لأنني أسألها في هذه الأمور
فاكتشفت أنها تريد أن تخترع
شيئا دون أن تطلب العلم
و تتمكن من المادة العلمية
التي تؤدي لهذا الاختراع
كانت تريد أن تتميز فحسب
أما العملية التعليمية في مصر
يوجد مشكلتين
أول مشكلة هي التقييم
للأسف في مصر
تقييم الطالب
يكون في مكان واحد
في زمان واحد
في شكل معين
يستهدف طالب معين
بدون أن نستوعب أنواع الذكاء المتعددة
أو طرق التعبير المختلفة لدي الطالب
و بالتالي نهمل جوانب كثيرة لدي الطالب
أما المشكلة الثانية
فهي مشكلة المعلم
و الجانب التربوي الذي يعاني منه الطالب
عندما نقيم الطالب
دائما نقيمه طبقا لمعايير محددة
لا تقيس احتياجات الطالب التي تجعله يتفوق
كمثال بسيط
في احدى قرى مصر
تتكلم الأم بمفردات قليلة جدا
طريقة تعبيرها عن نفسها
تتمحور في أربعين كلمة فقط
تشير الدراسات أن هذا يؤثر
على النمو المعرفي لدى الطالب
فيدخل الطالب المدرسة
لا يكون قادرا علي مواكبة
نمو و تطور بقية زملائه
يقال عليه فاشل
فبالتالي يتسرب من التعليم
و هنا تأتي أهمية المعلم
في مصر
نظرتنا للمعلم ليست كما ينبغي
يأخذ أقل المرتبات
مصروفات الدولة على العملية التعليمية
أقل من الدول المتقدمة
ذات الأساس التعليمي الرائع
الكفاءة المهنية عند المعلمين منخفضة
فكمثال
بطبيعة عملي أعلم المعلمين
المتفوقين في كلية التربية
أعلمهم المعلومات الأساسية في التربية
و أسألهم عن نظرية معينة في التعليم
فيجيبون بأنهم نسوها بعد الامتحان
فكلية التربية تمارس ممارسات ضد التربية
كما أن الحد الأدني للأجور
لأساتذة كلية التربية
ليس جيدا مثل الكليلت الأخرى
بالرغم من أن المعلم مسئول عن حياة أشخاص
أخرين مثل الطبيب و المهندس
اذا ما هو الحل ؟
يوجد حلول كثيرة
من احدى هذه الحلول
و هو تخصصي و مركز أبحاثي كلها
التعليم المرتكز على العلوم
, التكنولوجيا , الهندسة و الرياضيات
و هو خلق مناخ تربوي مناسب يرعى
مهارات القرن الواحد و العشرين
معتمدا على الاستفسار و حل المشاكل
بطريقة عملية و حياتية
جاعلا الطالب مركز الاهتمام
فلنبدأ بفكرة التعليم المتمركز حول الطالب
يجب أن نستوعب الطالب بذكاءه و اهتماماته
بحياته و خبراته
دون أن أفرض عليه شخصيتي كمعلم
فيجب أن أعرف كيف يحب
الطالب أن يعبر عن نفسه
يجب أن أعرف اهتماماته
كي أعطيه المادة العلمية من خلالها
يجب أن أعرف كيف أقيمه و أعلمه
فيجب أن يكون تمركز
التعليم علي الطالب و ليس المعلم
أما عن التعليم المعتمد علي الاستفسار
سأستدعي كريم
اذا اعتبرت نفسي في فصل
أنا المعلم
و كريم الطالب
يجلس المعلم مع الطالب سواسية
سأريكم كيف يحدث التعليم من خلال الاستفسار
كيف حالك ؟
جيد
في يوم من الأيام كنت ألعب رياضة
الركبي في منتخب مصر
و أحرزت هدف
ماذا تعرف عن الركبي
أعرف أنهم يجرون و يصطدمون ببعضهم البعض
و يرتدون بعض المعدات
ليس ضروريا أن يرتدوا معدات
لكن كيف تحرز هدفا ؟
أنه يحمل الكرة و يجري و يتفادي الخصم
حتي يصل لنهاية الملعب
بالضبط
اذا يأخذ اللاعب الكرة و يجري الي أخر
الملعب
حتي يعبر الخط و يحرز الهدف
ما الميزات التي يحتاجها
اللاعب كي يقوم بذلك ؟
سريع
جيد
قوي الجثة و عريض المنكبين
رائع
كيف نقيس تلك القوة ؟
لا أعلم و لكن ربما يكون للوزن أثر
أو يتم قياس نسبة العضلات في الجسم
اذا هو الوزن
فمثلا اذا كان هناك لاعبين
يجرون بنفس السرعة
الأول يزن ستين كيلوجرام
و الثاني يزن مئة كيلوجرام
من سيصطدم بالخصم أقوى ؟
أعتقد أنه اللاعب الذي يزن مئة كيلوجرام
هائل
و كان هذا درس في الفيزياء في قوة الدفع
شكرا كريم
و بدلا من أن أدرسه للطلبة بهذا الشكل الممل
و أقول أن قوة الدفع تساوي الوزن ضرب السرعة
و أجعلم يحفظون هذه المعادلة
و يحلون مليون سؤال كي يتفوقوا في الاختبار
أساعد الطالب كي يدرك الاجابة بنفسه
لأنني أؤمن أن الطالب يستطيع أن يتجاوب
و يتفاعل مع الطلبة و المعلم
ثاني نقطة هي التعليم المعتمد على حل
المشاكل العملية
فبدلا من أن أعطي الطالب المادة
العلمية بالطريقة التقليدة
أطلب منهم أن يحلوا مشكلة
هيا بنا نحل مشكلة معا ولنرى ما سيحدث
و أعتمد علي اجابة الطالب
المنطقية و التلقائية
و يكون دوري أن أطابق
اجاباتهم بالمادة العلمية
كمثال
في محاضرة
كنت أريدهم أن يحلوا مشكلة
و يجب أن تتلامس المشكلة مع
حياة الطلبة اليومية
فكانت المشكلة التحرش الجنسي
فجلسنا نفكر في هذه المشكلة
أخذ الطلبة بعض الوقت في بحث المشكلة
و اختاروا منطقة معينة في مصر
و قالوا أن التحرش يتمركز في أماكن مختلفة
و رسمنا هذه المناطق المختلفة
و توصلنا أننا يجب أن ننشئ مركز
قوات ضد التحرش الجنسي
في المنتصف
حتي تكون قريبة من كل هذه المناطق
هذا كان درس في الرياضيات
يدعي المحل الهندسي
حيث تكون تلك النقطة مركز
الدائرة التي تعبر بقية النقط
و كان هؤلاء طلبة كلية أداب
لم يكونوا مهتمين بالرياضيات
و لم يكونوا مهتمين بالرياضيات في المدرسة
و لكن عندما توصلوا لهذا الحل المنطقي
و قلت لهم أننا ندرس
هذه الأشياء بشكل أكاديمي
و يعتمد على علم الاحصاء
فرحوا جدا
و شعروا أنهم يستطيعون أن يفهموا الرياضيات
و استطاعوا أن يستبعدوا فكرة
"لماذا نتعلم هذه الأشياء أيها المعلم ؟"
فعندما استطعت أن أطابق أفكارهم
بالمادة العلمية
فرحوا و وثقوا بأنفسهم
و أخذوا يتساءلون عن صعوبة الرياضيات
في المدرسة
و بدأوا يفكرون في الرياضيات بشكل نقدي و
منطقي
و بدأوا يستوعبون
مشاكلهم اليومية بشكل مختلف
و بدأوا ينمون مهارات
لم يكن التعليم التقليدي يساعد في نموها
و هي مهارات القرن الواحد و العشرون
مثل مهارات التفكير النقدي
أو مهارات التفكير التحليلي
مهارات الالقاء
مهارات التواصل
كيفية استخدام الكمبيوتر
للأسف هذه الأشياء لا تعلمها الكتب
لابد من وجود مناخ تربوي سليم لتنمية هذه
المهارات
أهمية هذه المهارات تكمن في الوظائف
و مجالات العمل التي لم تكن موجودة
منذ خمس سنوات
فكان مستحيلا أن أعلم المادة العلمية
التابعة لهذه الوظائف منذ خمس سنوات
و لا نستطيع أن نتوقع المادة العلمية
التابعة للوظائف التي ستظهر بعد خمس سنوات
فكمثال
أصبح الأن يوجد وظيفة الخبير التحليلي
لشبكات التواصل الاجتماعي
لم يكن هذا المجال موجودا منذ خمس سنوات
فهو شخص يحلل ما يحدث
في شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي
و يستطيع أن يتوقع ما يعجب الناس و يحمسهم
كي أنمي هذا لدى الطالب
يجب أن أخلق مناخ تربوي سليم كي
يتعلم فيه الطالب هذه المهارات
كي يتعلم كيف يتعلم
و لذلك من المهم أن نركز على المهارات
و ليس المحتوى
لأن المحتوي دائم التغيير
و العلم يتطور بسرعة جدا
و ما ندرسه الأن
لا نعلم اذا كان سيظل كما هو خلال خمس سنوات
مثلا
في كتاب الفيزياء في المدرسة
مكتوب أن الطاقة النووية رائعة
و لا يوجد منها أي أضرار
لأن بعد حادثة شيرنوبل في 1986
أخذت كل الاحتياطات
للأسف هذا الكتاب كان قد تم تأليفه قبل
حادثة فوكوشيما في اليابان
و يحب أن يتم تغيير هذا الكتاب
لأن المفاعلات النووية بالفعل
تستطيع أن تحدث دمارا
أخر نقطة سأتحدث عنها
هي فكرة دمج المواد العلمية
لا أدرس كل مادة منفصلة
فمثلا في التاريخ
في حرب طروادة
عندما لجئ الجيش للحيلة
و أدخل حصان كبير خشبي ملئ
بالجنود الى المدينة كهدية
خرج الجنود في الليل
و فتحوا الأبواب
و سمحوا للجيش أن يدخل و ينتصر
في التاريخ
يمكن أن أدرس هذه القصة بالأسامي
و التواريخ و أجعله يحفظ
و أجعله يدخل الامتحان و يكتب ما
حفظ بدون فهم
و لكنه لا يتعلم فعلا
انه يحفظ من أجل الامتحان و سينساه بعدها
و لكن يمكن أن نقدم المادة العلمية
نحكي لهم قصة طروادة
فما هي قواعد الرياضيات التي نحتاجها
حتي نعرف سعة الحصان
و عدد الأفراد الذين يمكن أن يكونوا بالداخل
ما هي المساحة السطحية للحصان ؟
أما في الفيزياء
ما هي القوات التي نحتاجها كي ندفع الحصان
ما قدر الاحتكاك المعادي لدفع الحصان ؟
في الهندسة
ما هي المواد اللازمة لبناء الحصان ؟
ما هي أبعاد الحصان ؟
في الفنون
يمكن أن يرسموا هذا الحصان
و أجعلهم يتخيلوه و يلونوه
و يصنعوا نموذج مصغر
في الفنون اللغوية
أجعلهم يكتبون القصة بطريقة مختلفة
و هكذا
فاستطعت أن أدمج كل المواد معا
بدون أن يشعر الطالب أنه يدرس المادة
من أجل الامتحان فقط
أصبح عنده احساس الملكية لما يتعلمه
و اقتنع بما يدرسه
و الطلبة بطبيعتهم لديهم علم بهذه الأشياء
فمثلا
كثيرون لا يحبون التفاضل و التكامل
اكتشفنا أن الكلب يستخدم التفاضل و التكامل
فاذا رميت للكلب عصا في البركة
سيجري الكلب على الأرض
ثم يجري على المياه
هذه مسألة حسابية نستطيع أن نحلها
صعوبة الأمر تكمن في ربط ما يحدث في الفصل
بما يحدث في الحياة اليومية
لهذا
في يوم من الأيام
عندما أصبح وزير التربية و التعليم في مصر
أريد أن أخلق هذا المناخ التربوي
السليم للطالب
أريد أن أعطيه الفرصة كي يتعلم كيف يتعلم
أريده أن يستطيع أن يربط
بين حياته و ما يحدث في الفصل
بدون وجود فاصل بينهم
أريد أن يكون عند الطالب
المهارات الحياتية اللازمة
كي يتعايش مع الواقع
كي يعمل في مجال يحبه و يعبر عن شخصيته
أو كي يحل المشاكل
اليومية في حياته أيا كانت
فيجب أن يكون الطالب في مناخ تربوي سليم
لاّنني أنتمي الى مدرسة فكرية
تقول أنني كمعلم
لا أستطيع أن أعلم شيئا
كل ما أستطيع أن أفعله
هو أن أخلق المناخ التربوي السليم
سأخلقه
شكرا